welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and one of the more mysterious
easter eggs in the loki finale has
finally been revealed
and like any clue we find in these shows
this revelation actually becomes its own
nexus event whose historical
implications extend far beyond the event
horizon
causing me to bolt awake and a cold
sweat gasping
magnificent the loki episode vi opening
imagery packed in
dozens of marvel references including
this mystery ship that many of us
spotted but struggled to identify right
away
loki head writer kate herron confirmed
that fans might recognize this ship
and quote it's been in a few things and
we have now learned this is actually the
ship
of the collector tanelier tavonne
benicio del toro from guardians of the
galaxy
it was seen in the background of nowhere
in avengers infinity war as thanos cast
a reality stone illusion of
torturing tyvon in order to trick gamora
and the other guardians
in various shots you can see this ship's
golden plating covering its blue frame
and wings extending from beneath the
cockpit angled downward when parked and
this was confirmed by loki vfx
supervisor brad parker in an interview
there was a hidden detail or two there
are a few
little elements that we pass by one
might be the collector's ship um can't
confirm nor deny that
cute brad but we catch your draft he
refers to them as
elements a term used by these movies and
shows editors and effects crews for
marvel studios vast archive of assets
and elements across
properties the collector ship was
designed for past marvel titles and now
shows like loki have the ability to
access the elements for their shows but
now this brings up the questions of
what the hell was the collector doing
out here and why was it so important for
marvel studios to bring him back like
this the collector is considered one of
marvel's elders of the universe
alongside the grand master jeff
goldblum's character in thor ragnarok
tyvon
dedicates his life to collecting
artifacts a purpose directly linked to
his
immortality and while it seemed like
thanos was about to destroy him infinity
war
this whole interrogation faded away in
red smoke as part of thanos reality
stone illusion the reality stone of
course was last seen hidden in the
collector's vault by the asgardians
in the thor the dark world post-credits
scene now notice how after thanos drops
the illusion the collector ship
now appears to be a flaming wreck if
that is the same ship though we never
actually see tyvonne's remains
actually while he vanishes he does a
silly little wave something i've always
loved from the scene because
thanos must have hilariously conjured
this from his own imagination like he
did with blocks and ribbons and bubbles
but i've always looked at it a different
way like maybe tavonne
in defeat as he handed over the reality
stone might have allowed thanos to
mirror his likeness so that he could
better manipulate gamora just because
that little wave makes it look like
tavonne might have helped pull something
over on the guardians
just based on that gesture i've always
read that moment as maybe the real
tavonne
surviving somehow and now with this
ship's appearance in loki i just think
his survival is more likely in the mcu
he is an elder of the universe
now we don't know when this sighting in
loki takes place because as
has been confirmed by the loki head
writer all moments in loki are really
set simultaneously
as all the other moments in mcu history
but in the seconds that we see his ship
it is soaring away from the galaxy that
contained all the voices we had
witnessed throughout the infinity saga
as this universe condenses in a big
crunch before exploding again in a big
bang
that would mean tavonne could have
survived long into the future of the mcu
as we previously knew it into a new
universal cycle we will soon see
one such cycle as the collector is
confirmed to return in episode 2 of
marvel studios what if
actually the latest featurette directly
referenced loki's imagery of the sacred
timeline fracturing
as the context within which what if is
taking place
reality is not a straight line every
passing moment
is a chance for a new offshoot a new
variation
in fact there are more realities than
you can possibly fathom
an infinite number of what is the
previous trailers have confirmed episode
two will feature
star-lord t'challa teaming up with yondu
kraglin
taserface and korath and more on a
mission that takes them
into the collector's compound on nowhere
where t'challa will apparently meet
howard the duck and it will end with
t'challa and yondu
tag-teaming to fight a version of the
collector who now looks
jacked and wears special armor with
cybernetic enhancements one of the most
interesting things we just learned about
marvel's what if is that the head writer
apparently had to scrap an
episode concept because marvel studios
came back to him saying it was too
similar to half of james gunn's planned
plot
for guardians of the galaxy vol 3.
actually when gunn heard about this he
responded that he had no clue what this
was and he was real curious about how
that could be the case but if you dread
looking at your credit card statements
like their pictures from your 8th grade
dance
who thought that haircut would be a good
idea and who has taken pictures of these
children you're not alone
debt can feel crippling but upstart can
help you on your path to financial
freedom upstart is the fast and easy way
to pay off your debt with a personal
loan
all online whether it's paying off
credit cards consolidating high interest
debt or funding personal expenses
over half a million people have used
upstart to get one fixed monthly payment
upstart knows you are more than just
your credit
score and is expanding access to
affordable credit unlike other lenders
upstart considers your income and your
current employment to find you a smarter
rate for your loan with a five minute
online rate check you can see your rate
up front for loans between one thousand
and fifty thousand dollars you can
receive funds as fast as one business
day after accepting your loan find out
how upstart can lower your monthly
payments today when you go to
upstart.com
new rockstars that is upstart.com new
rockstars don't forget to use our url to
let them know that we sent you go to
upstart.com
new rockstars there was also an odd
report back in 2015 in which zoe saldana
suggested she planned to appear on a
guardian set again with beniso del toro
in retrospect that could have been the
scene that they ended up shooting for
infinity war or
since james gunn has reportedly had his
volume 3 story locked in for several
years
half of that script might have involved
the guardians reuniting with the
collector which is now
why this what if episode casts a
collector instead
in this short-lived antagonistic role
instead of something
else that james gunn plans on doing with
him one of the most interesting things
about the collector in the mcu is a
quote from benicio del toro when he
described his character as a kind of
altruistic survivalist he's kind of like
noah from noah's ark he believes that
there's gonna be
a big catastrophe in the galaxy in the
whole
universe and he's collecting all these
creatures to preserve them somehow so
there's an element of
altruism looking back the mcu was
certainly headed toward catastrophe of
course thanos's snap but based on thanos
sacking the collector's vault and
stealing his most treasured collection
the reality stone
i don't think the collector saw thanos
coming nor was thanos the catastrophe
the collector was planning for
especially since thanos's snap likely
would have impacted half of the
collector's living collection anyway or
even the collector himself
but now based on the collector's ship
appearing in loki
i wonder if the catastrophe he was
actually bracing for was
kang and the rupturing of the sacred
timeline because if you go through this
imagery frame by frame his ship is
racing
away from the galaxy and toward the
barrier of a black hole that borders
another black hole which we realized was
presumably tracing the geographical path
one would have to take to traverse
across universes
if one could hypothetically even survive
that journey because we don't
see the collector ship make it it kind
of looks like everything gets caught in
the big crunch in the big bang that
follows and according to physics
nothing should be able to escape a black
hole but then again this is also marvel
and inter-universal travel might just
stretch out your face a little but i
like to think the collector
did survive that journey and as an elder
of the universe it was his purpose to
survive kang and loki's multiversal
crisis by physically bypassing the
barrier between
universal strands and escaping the
crisis formed when those strands collide
in with each other and i hope that part
of his genesis protocol are the members
of the guardians of the galaxy
specifically groot which remember was a
specimen that he was notably obsessed
with collecting
what is that thing
there i'm crude i never thought i'm good
sir you must allow me to pay you now so
that i may own your caucus
at the moment of your death of course
maybe because the collector knew
that when a groot is destroyed its
pieces become roots
for new life to spawn something quite
useful to someone who considers himself
the noah of the multiverse but what do
you think is the collector's future in
the mcu
comment down below and you can support
new rockstars by checking out our
various merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com follow me on
instagram and twitter at eavos follow
and subscribe to new rockstars thanks
for watching bye
[Music]
foreign